Incluso de manera más general,
en realidad, los machos no son tan importantes
en la vida de un gran número de insectos.
Entre los insectos sociales, las abejas, las avispas y las hormigas,
los individuos que se ven todos los días,
las hormigas que van y vienen de su azucarero,
las abejas productoras de miel que revolotean de flor en flor,
todas son exclusivamente hembras.
Siempre hemos tenido dificultades
para entender las razones de todo esto, durante milenios.
Los antiguos griegos sabían que había una clase de abejas, los zánganos,
que son más grandes que las trabajadoras,
aunque desaprobaron vehementemente la pereza de estos zánganos,
porque veían como solo pululaban alrededor de la colmena
hasta el momento del vuelo de apareamiento; allí están los machos.
No hacen nada hasta el vuelo de apareamiento,
y no participan en la recolección de néctar ni de polen.
Los griegos no pudieron averiguar el sexo de los zánganos,
en parte por la confusión creada a raíz de la capacidad de picar de las abejas,
porque les resultaba difícil creer
que un animal que llevara un arma pudiera ser una hembra.
Aristóteles trató de involucrarse también.
Sugirió: "Está bien, si los individuos que pican son los machos..."
Luego no lo tuvo tan claro porque eso habría significado
que los machos también fueran los que cuidaban de los jóvenes en la colonia,
y para él esto parecía algo completamente imposible.
Así concluyó de que tal vez las abejas tuvieran órganos de ambos sexos
en el mismo individuo,
idea que no es tan descabellada, ya que algunos animales hacen eso,
pero en realidad nunca supo resolverlo.
Y saben, incluso hoy en día, mis alumnos por ejemplo,
llaman a todos los animales que ven, incluso a los insectos, machos.
Y cuando les digo que los feroces soldados del ejército de hormigas
con sus mandíbulas gigantes, que suelen a defender la colonia
son todas hembras,
no parecen fiarse de mí del todo.
(Risas)
Y claro, todas las películas, "Antz", "Bee Movie",
retratan al personaje principal de los insectos sociales como macho.
Bueno, ¿qué importancia tiene esto?
Solo son películas. Son ficción.
Salen animales que hablan.
¿Qué importancia tiene si hablan como Jerry Seinfeld? (Risas)
Creo que sí importa,
y es un problema que en realidad es parte de algo más profundo
que tiene consecuencias para la medicina y la salud
y muchos otros aspectos de la vida.
Todos saben que los científicos usan lo que llamamos sistemas de modelo,
que son criaturas --ratas blancas o moscas de la fruta--
que son una especie de sustitutos
para el resto de los animales, incluidos los humanos.
Y la idea es que lo que es válido para una persona
también es cierto para la rata blanca.
Y por lo general, es así.
Pero la idea de un sistema de modelo puede llevarse demasiado lejos.
Y creo que hemos usado
a los machos de cualquier especie como representantes del sistema modelo.
Ellos son la norma.
Dictan la forma de hacer las cosas.
Y se ha considerado a las hembras como una especie de variante...
algo aparte que solo se estudia después de tener las bases asentadas.
Bueno, de vuelta a los insectos.
Creo que eso significa
que la gente simplemente no entendió qué tenía delante de ellos.
Porque supusieron que el mundo
estaba poblado en gran parte por machos
y que las hembras solo tenían un papel menor.
Pero al hacer eso, perdemos de vista realmente lo que es la naturaleza misma.
Y también podemos perder de vista
cómo los seres vivos, incluidos los humanos, pueden variar.
Y creo que por eso hemos usado machos como modelos
en un gran número de investigaciones médicas,
algo que ahora sabemos que es un problema
si queremos que los resultados se apliquen tanto a hombres como a mujeres.
Y, por último, lo que me encanta en los insectos
es algo que mucha gente encuentra desconcertante en ellos.
Tienen unos pequeños, diminutos cerebros con muy poca capacidad cognitiva,
por lo menos tal y como nosotros percibimos dicha capacidad.
Tienen un comportamiento complicado, pero carecen de cerebros complicados.
Por eso, no podemos pensar en ellos como si fueran algo insignificante
porque no hacen las cosas a nuestra manera.
Me gusta que sea difícil antropomorfizar a los insectos,
mirarlos y solo pensar que son criaturas insignificantes
en exoesqueletos y con 6 patas.
(Risas)
De hecho, hay que aceptarlos en sus propios términos,
porque los insectos nos hacen dudar de lo que se considera normal o natural.
Ya saben, la gente escribe ficción y habla de universos paralelos.
Especula sobre lo sobrenatural,
y tal vez sobre espíritus de difuntos que caminan entre nosotros.
El encanto del otro mundo
es parte de la razón por la que la gente quiere adentrarse en lo paranormal.
Pero en lo que a mí respecta,
¿porqué querer ver gente muerta
cuando se pueden investigar unos insectos vivos?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)